thumbs up so part one is done that's my
expression I mean I can't find out the
number if I like but it's not going to
help me with part two hence our
otherwise determine how many years mr.
woo how much I have to invest before I
get to that number okay now if all I was
doing was investing a thousand dollars
and there was no interest how long would
it take it would take exactly thirty
years because a thousand dollars 2,000
3,000 4,000 but that's not what's
happening interest is being applied so
whatever number whatever answer I get
down the end here I'm gonna do a sense
check it embedded me under 30 otherwise
this is the worst super account of all
time okay how am I going to get toward
an answer I see a pattern right I can
say if this is what it is after three
years then after n years it ought to be
and I'm gonna try and fill in the
pattern right well have a look there's
so much structure here surely you can
recognize what's going on right if you
have a color there another color I've
got a one I've got a two I've got a
three
do you notice they all start the same
way when this guy you see that I suppose
I should say they in the same way okay
that's always the last term okay and
then what happens is it just sort of
climbs up in power like this you see
that until such point as I get to what
number when do I end when I get to the
enter which is the third one in this
case the second one this case and so on
okay
so therefore the very first term I'm
gonna write here will be $1,000 and how
many lots of interests have been applied
to it
n times right stop causing it and lots
of interest because after all this is
the very first bit of money that you put
in there and it's been in there for ten
years you care with that what's the next
term
it's gonna be one less you see it climbs
down to one etcetera so alright whoops I
didn't live that I'll write the next one
plus dot dot dot okay now where is it
going to end it's gonna end it always
ends on this spot right that's always
the last one okay now just for the sake
of it I'm gonna put a 1 here and then it
seems a bit redundant but you'll see why
in a second think back when we were
doing some earlier questions right at
this point I'm now ready to say I
recognize a series here I can actually
label and say it's a particular kind of
series what particular kind of series is
it this is a GP so I'm gonna say the
words this is a GP what three features
define a GP well there are there's a
starting term there's a common ratio and
then there's how many terms there are
right so what is a what's the first term
now I've written it from big to small
right but I can write it backwards if I
want to and that's probably easier for
me because this is an easier number to
write yeah so I'm gonna say a equals
this guy here said all right I could say
R equals 1.05 that's the common ratio
every single time how many terms are
there now if you recall when our earlier
examples we looked at like a concrete
number here right and you'd say
something like oh there are seven terms
or eight terms and I sent to you before
I don't like writing N equals seven or N
equals eight because when you get to a
question like this you would say
something like N equals n which means
nothing right but there are really n
terms in here so that's why I'm going to
write in terms be careful sometimes
there are n plus 1 terms sometimes there
n minus 1 terms how do I know without a
shadow of a doubt that there are exactly
in terms are not one more and one less
how would you reason it through so it
ends here right if I were to count up to
that end right it goes one two three
four five six all the way up until em
right suppose my last term was zero like
that how many terms would there be now
there's an extra one you see that I
would count one two three four five six
all the way up to N and then there's an
extra one a plus one so you have to look
out for these things we often have
off-by-one errors and they come up in
spots like this okay now just before we
leave off this this is not the only GP
you could have formed right do you see
all the way through this term every
single term has a couple of common
factors do you notice that what are the
common factors that appear every single
time a thousand and 1.5 so if I wanted I
could have factored all of that out and
then I would have a different GP okay
it's going to come up with the same
answer but just so that you know you can
form different GPS with the same set of
terms is that okay all right why did I
go to the effort of pointing out that
it's it's a GP it's so that I don't have
to write every single term it's so that
I can use a formula what's the formula I
can use for the sum of a GP there are
two formulas right do you remember what
the two are yeah that's right I'll give
you a clue they both start with an A and
they both are fractions okay so there's
this one and then what goes up here one
minus R to the N if you're thinking
about it without the one minus R to the
N what is that that's a special version
of this what is this guy it's the
limiting son that's right so you know
how some series converge on a particular
value that's when you can use this this
does not it just gets bigger and bigger
forever so this is kind of not much use
to us okay this is nothing anyway you
can write the sum of a cheap here what's
the other form it still starts with a
name and it's still a fraction
see these two I can flip them around
right now they're both the same formula
then literally both the same formula but
which ones you would you prefer to use
in this case I think I prefer this one
what makes me tear ten towards the
second one rad in the first yeah see
that are there on the bottom there it's
going to give me one point oh five minus
one it'll be a positive number if I
stuck it in this one and give me a
negative better give me negative two but
I just don't want to have negatives I
just get confused okay right let's pop
it into this formula in are you ready
here we go a 1000 times 1.05 there's a
in the brackets 1.05 sorry did I write
the red one yes I did ^ ^ have a look a
formula it's just it's just M right
because that's that's how many turns
there are that's why I bothered to write
that down so I know what goes there okay
take away 1 and then the bottom how's
your brain doing
you have turned this wordy problem into
a simple GP okay this is a N